many of those suspicions about the
Democratic process stem from former
president Trump's false claims about the
2020 election Scott McFarland is still
here he stayed another day to talk about
the effect on this year's races Scott
always good to have you in the studio
good morning to you good to be here Gail
our CBS News Review of every Federal and
Statewide race shows up the nearly 590
Republican candidates there are 308 who
we categorize as election deniers look
at this in the U.S house it's 238 of 436
it's a majority in the U.S Senate again
it's a majority in gubernatorial races
same number in Secretary of State races
Nationwide it's nearly half and
secretaries of state would help
administer future elections what do we
mean by election denier CBS News is a
lengthy informal definition it includes
those who've questioned the legitimacy
of Biden's election who won't
acknowledge he's the duly elected
president those who say the election was
stolen and those who've repeated
disproven claims of of fraud among the
308 are candidates from 48 different
states across the country and it
includes Republican incumbents who are
questioning the validity of the very
ballots upon which they were elected to
boy look at those numbers yeah it's
pretty remarkable stuff there well five
days and counting thank you very much
Scott and a reminder for you election
day is just five days away five days
we'll have full coverage for you here on
CBS starting at eight o'clock Eastern on
November 8th